there's a lot of people that are
concerned that the
Pfizer vaccine by the way of which I
took two shots
no booster yet
is unsafe
what do you say to people that say that
no they should not
fear something like that it's completely
wrong there is no
medical product in the history of
humanity that have been tested as much
as this vaccine has been administered to
hundreds of millions of people and
because of the importance of covet they
have been scrutinized those people
constantly right now Healthcare
authorities are looking for every single
signal around the world of people that
they got the vaccine and try to see if
it is vaccine related or not there are
electronic medical records that will
tell us when and what happened to a
person when he did got the vaccine and
we know now
more we have so high certainty that it
is so safe
exactly as the data sit
says about this vaccine more than any
other product
they should not be afraid of something
like that and they should not listen to
information that it is misinformation
that is spread on purpose
well I don't like the word
misinformation because
you know again back to the Soviet Union
anyone who opposes the state is
spreading misinformation so you can
basically call anything misinformation
that's the unfortunate times we live in
is
you can call anyone you can basically
call anybody a liar and say I'm the sole
possessor of the truth and just no
offense to me just because you wear a
tie doesn't mean you're
and you're more likely to be in the
possession of the truth than anyone else
so I wouldn't disagree with that at all
I don't think that that's somebody who's
not wearing a time and as you can people
can see that I'm not wearing a tie and
you are but it's not about
um uh
being able those that they have the
power
to to impose on the others the stigma
that uh you what you're saying is
misinformation
but there are a few things that the
society we have accomplished and science
is one of them
and data is an analytics of data is
another one and to say that something
which is highly scientific by people
that they're not scientists
uh I I I think that it is not what you
are describing what used to happen in
Soviet Union or in any other autocratic
regime in the world right now but I
definitely do think
that uh the scientists this is the
public science communicators have
listened to over covet have really
disappointed me because they have not
spoken with empathy they haven't
sufficiently in my view have put their
ego aside and really listen to people
yes people that don't have a PhD people
who have not really you know
maybe you've not even taken like a
biology course in college or something
like that but still they they they have
children they they worry they fear they
don't know who to trust they don't know
if they should listen to the CEO of
Pfizer who might have other incentives
in mind who might just care about money
and nothing else and so they just use
common sense and they ask questions and
I think to them talking down to them as
if they're not intelligent so on is
something
scientists have done almost like rolled
their eyes and that disappoints me
because I think that's kind of what is
the source of division look humility is
a virtue yes and uh yes the fact that
you are educated doesn't mean that you
are having either humility or empathy or
you have good human qualities this was
never
and will never be a metric of judging
this type of Virtues those that they do
this
they're wrong and actually they they are
not doing good service to the public
health because they are undermining
people are not stupid they see if you're
not uh be respecting them and if you're
not respecting their need to learn
because that affects their health the
health of the mother of the kids so I
fully agree with you that we should be
very patient to explain again and again
and again what is happening and the vast
majority of the people that they don't
get vaccinations right now is because
they're afraid it's not for any other
reason it's not that they have a an
agenda what I'm saying it is there is a
small number of people that they have
make business
for them
to
profit from this anxiety I'll give you
an example
I have been arrested by FBI this is what
someone wrote I I read it I laughed I
mean
okay this is where they take there was a
reason why they wrote it that the Pfizer
CEO was arrested FBI because they want
to create doubts in the minds of the
people that they're afraid
and say look if the IRS the team likely
I will not do the vaccine but they left
a week later
the wife of the Pfizer CEO died
there is a picture in the in this
website of my wife
someone sent to me
now I'm pissed I'm not laughing I try to
find my kids to tell them if you read
something mom is fine don't worry
then I remember that she has
very old parents back in Greece we start
calling them to making sure because so
you know that that will be picked up by
quick newspapers and they will republish
it okay they are those people that throw
these things they know very well but my
wife didn't die and died because she was
vaccinated right so this is the
narratives that they are on purpose
forming
to profit
from the stress and the
anxiety of good people and that's
something I have to kind of people that
listen to this that kind of doubt
institutions
I do also want to say that there's
quite a few folks who realize they can
make money
from
saying the man is lying to you
the government is lying to you
it's all corrupt
it's all a scam
big farmer is lying to you they're
manipulating you
I'm surprised at how much money can be
made with that and it's sad so you have
to just as people use their common sense
to uh be skeptical when listening to
politicians and Powerful figures they
should be skeptical to also when
listening to sort of the the conspiracy
theorists or not even the conspiracy
theorists but people who raise questions
about institutions think think on your
own think critically with an open mind
that everyone could be manipulating you
but also everybody has the capacity to
do good and I think uh science in this
pure form not when entangled
institutions
is a beautiful thing and in the hands of
many companies it is a beautiful thing
at scale